what do you have no this is Stanton
Friedman I'm a nuclear physicist with a
very strong interest in flying saucers
I'm in Kansas City Missouri
July 24th 1991 I'm here to do an
interview with Gerald Anderson a very
important witness with regard to
recovery of a crashed flying saucer in
Mexico in July 1947 we have just had a
visit with a polygraph examiner who says
he has seen no evidence of deception
this is after spending several hours of
myself and Gerald mostly with Gerald a
full report will be forthcoming so with
that we will talk to Jeru Landers
who state your name please my name is
Gerald Anderson where we were born and
when I was born October 4th 1941 in
Episode II okay and give me a summary of
what happened in 1947 with regard to a
crashed flying saucer pneumix well we
had just moved to Albuquerque New Mexico
on July 4th 1947 this was approximately
there was the day Dustin with my uncle
Ted
my cousin Victor my father my brother
Glen and myself we drove down to the
plains of san agustin which is west of
Socorro New Mexico
Magdelena battle area we were down there
looking for banded in moss agate which
according to my uncle Ted
was in the area my brother being an
amateur rock had and wanted to get some
of this and that was a way of showing us
around there yeah they had relatives
down Magdelena they wanted to introduce
a student so we had gone down there and
we got down in a horse Prince area and
had driven her off on to the plains down
an old rutted Road for a mile or so and
seemed like a long ways we parked the
car got out of the car and walked down a
hillside of semi forest Vegas you said
had pinyon trees the scrub oak and stuff
like that on and we'd walk to that scrub
up into cedar and walked down the
hillside to an arroyo a dry wash and it
walked South down a dry wash to work
where the maggots were supposed to be at
and as we came around a bend in the
Arroyo that had pinyon and cedar trees
growing on we were able to see farther
ahead down the Arroyo on a next
Ridgeline there was a large silver disc
shaped object was embedded in the side
of the ridge line
is debris and wreckage and Stern about
the area but mainly this thing was
intact I would estimate its size from an
adult perspective to be something like
35 feet in diameter I've heard other
other people who were there say they
thought it was like 50 feet as an adult
I would say about 35 feet diameter quite
large when we got up to it there were
four bodies they're not human there was
two of them were obviously dead one of
them was obviously very badly injured
and one of the apparently suffered no
ill effects or didn't appear to be
injured and was was handled before a
little while I was just sitting there
next to the one was still alive were
they right next to the vehicle right
next to it right under the edge and this
craft had apparently come in from the
east bounced off one Ridgeline went
plowing through this Royal area and it
crashed into the ridgeline embedded
itself and they were sitting back under
the edge it was kind of tilted up like
this and they were sitting back under
the edge here and I'm assuming that this
one creature that was all right had
latest material on the ground but it
looked like unrolled the tinfoil that
these other three creatures were laying
like it was trying to I could do a
person in shock input on
kind of thing and apparently it had some
boxes there around it and had apparently
been trying to get first aid or help
these other creatures when we first got
there and as we approached the creature
gear back like this like it was in
fairness like we're going to hurt it was
very long and trying to communicate with
the adults were it seemed the calm down
and just set there and kind of look back
and forth watching him apparently trying
to figure out what was going on like
what did it look like a little bit these
creatures
all of them were all about 4 foot tall
or four and a half feet tall they had
very large heads that were shaped larger
on the top and they kind of tapered down
not to a real sharp point but just take
her down where they were thin and very
large very large oval shape or almond
shape and as you could say black eyes
that had there were so shiny they had
almost a bluish tint to them when the
light reflected off them their skin
coloration
the best way I could describe that is
kind of a blueish tinted milky one it
was it looked like someone in shell and
the ones that were laying on the ground
really really looked more than way more
blue
luckily how about ears nose now there
was there was no visible here's a
creatures except like if you is just to
cover your ear like this to whether it
was just a riser in a hole without you
know your earlobe and the rest of the
year they're about nose
it was the nose was very very small
almost imperceptible just like to hold
straight in and the lips were just a
straight line it was like a cut and you
didn't see any this will looks like we
have it was just a slit and what never
going to sound part what hair color
there was no hair there was unclearly
ball and no sentence I never heard of
sound one
creatures and just see fingers the OP
they had though they had fingers like
this they didn't have a little finger
they just had the thumb and three extra
digits except the center digit was
longer and the other two were about the
same size they were very long and
slender looked very delicate and I've
made the statement before now make it
again I think it made excellent
violinist because of the structure of
their hands they were wearing one-piece
suits all of them were dressed exactly
the same it was sort of a real shiny
silvery gray color no zippers buttons no
I saw no zippers no buttons and signet
no no in sickness the only thing that
was different you know they all had this
but the only thing that was different
from the the silvery great thing was
that down the seen one like it was a
seam on a shoulder around the collar was
trimmed what appeared to be more like
cording then the suits were continuous
with their foot gear you could see right
about this area down it seemed to be
less pliable it was a pair like this was
a stripper area like they were boots or
shoes or something
but they were all dressed exactly the
same okay so you and your family are
talking back and forth wondering what
was going on what did your family say I
mean well I'd say anything yeah my
brother are the first remarks I heard
made was that's a goddamn spaceship you
know there was bodies up there I was
told not to go through which idea and
how old was your brother at the time he
was in his early twenty five twenty
twenty-one he was a lot older than you
oh yes considerably we when we got up
there I can we ended off to one side the
same cocked up and I was standing here
the bodies were here and everybody else
was kind of down here except my cousin
Victor over here claimed looking in his
gaping hole on the side of this this
disk and shaped just like a discus
except for a round dome was up on top
and I was this big game in gashing or we
could see inside of like a double Hall
how big length McHale Mulligan well it
covered the greater majority from the
center of the craft and it was
like a gaping hole and I'm thinking us
like about 3035 feet diameter so we're
talking about 17 feet maybe now most of
most that one side was ripped open like
that and you can see inside and you can
see another double halt like in there
and there was these rows of components
that was on there and there was lights
that flashed on awesomer study some were
flashing there was a lot of debris and
stuff hanging out of the hole there was
evidence that there apparently good fire
it looked like it had been burnt along
the edge there the gauge now this wasn't
a guess that could have been caused by
the thing coming into the ground it
wasn't at the leading edge of the
vehicle no no this was in a sidelight it
almost appeared was elliptical it almost
appeared is this something the same
shape as the disc we were looking at had
hit that that same one and hit the disc
and left and imprinted pretty closely
approximated the outside diameter of the
disc itself and it appeared to be Cade
inward okay and kind of like hit like
this and just crumpled a caved-in and
ripped it open okay so you're there you
take all this and everybody's mystified
what were the circumstances outside hot
cold very very hot and correct well to
me being the first time in New Mexico
back east that dry heat was just like
being inside up it was unbelievable to
me and that was the odd part about this
second closer you got to it the cooler
it was and standing under in the shade
there next to these creatures bodies it
was like refrigerated air-conditioning
and did you feel air coming out of this
thing or no it was just like it was
ambient and I remember reaching up and
putting my hand on the side of it that I
think I was afraid it was going to hit
my head because there was enough room
for me as a small child you know I was
pricing the same size these creatures to
walk up under there and standard but I
kind of did like that put my hand up
against this thing what it feeling it
was ice-cold it felt like it just came
out of her frozen was it smooth was it
it was very smooth
had a very smooth texture to it was
obviously made out of metal it was very
solid and very cold ice-cold and there
was a smell in the area its no volatile
acred like acetone and that seemed to be
coming out of that gash and smell but
the closer you got this thing the cooler
was so I kind of remained there and I
missed it while they were over here my
father and
and Ted and my brother and uncle Ted was
trying to talk to the Senate in Spanish
and of course it didn't understand where
he said and dad tried to talk to him and
they tried you know sign language and
that didn't work and I don't know for
some reason I just I reached out and
touched it just one it was laying this
to me and when I touched it I realized
you know jump back it scared me and
startled me did I suddenly realize that
these weren't dolls I thought they were
plastic dolls and I you know I still in
my mind these are moving dolls until I
touched it and I realized you know this
was a death and I've been I'd seen dead
relatives before I unfortunately had
made a mistake one time touching
numerology
the casket I just knew this is a dead
thing and it scared me and I ran around
behind my father and my uncle and the
same was sitting there on the ground and
it kept looking back and forth it just
had its hand like it said flapping just
can't believe that important between the
three of them like it was trying to
understand and all of a sudden he just
turned it looked right straight at me
between my uncle Ted of myself and this
is when it was just like an explosion of
things in my head things I started you
know feeling just terrible depression
loneliness and fear and just you know
awful awful feelings that just suddenly
burst into my mind I don't know if that
meant that it was communicating with me
and I was the only one there I can
communicate with because I was a kid I
don't know I turned it and ran and I ran
across the Arroyo and up on the area
that had bounced off up during the crash
and was just standing or looking down at
the singing
my family often additions I could see
cattle grazing I can see a windmill and
could see dust trails I don't fight out
of planes out there and oh I was there
profile I did I came back down I guess
we were there Victor was in when I got
that down there Victor was up in the
crack and Ted yelled at him to get out
of there and glad I went over grabbed me
by the building jerking lights your
brother yeah and jerking off is get out
of cause of saying that explode and kill
us all you know and course he went
prowling around in there
I was kind of standing off one side
looking that's why I knew that there was
I could look off these rocks that I was
standing over right into this thing
that's why I knew you know about the
lights and components and stuff and then
I and I heard other people talking in a
turned and it was a group of people
coming up the Arroyo from out on the
plains for the South they'd come up
there and of course they walked up was
talking and how many there was a an
older man and five younger students
voice girls there's three boys and two
girls and they were all you know
introducing talking to my father in my
brother what the older one look like the
commander of the screen young man he was
a very tall man very big man he was
wearing a pith helmet when he first came
up when I was kind of exploring us and
he was bald I know that because he had
taken it off he had done this he replied
to the handkerchief and put it back
Baldy man and he had a round face it was
very ready complected it's a big man and
he apparently was a doctor because he's
they kept calling doctor and I
understand it was an archeological group
it was out there on some kind of a
southern thing and they talked and he
apparently was able to speak several
foreign languages and he tried to talk
to this creature several times in
different languages again to know
how do not happened to be there and he
seen the thing well they claimed that
they saw they said they saw this and
come down the night before of 20 you
know and they thought it was a meteorite
and they had talked about well in the
morning you know well we'll go there and
see this where this meteor kingdoms
that's what they thought it was and when
the Sun came up the next morning you
know and they got about their business
and got up and somebody looked over and
said you know they saw the shiny metal
and stuff across the plains there and
they realized what the meteorite it may
have been an airplane and then Christ so
they all decided to go over there and
see if there was anybody who was alive
you know it was her to even help they
had driven them no they walked over
terribly the way I understand and it's
quite ways across that point so it
hadn't taken very long time to do this
or they may have that vehicle I don't
know that's an assumption I think on my
part with
okay so they're around with my family
across the the plains nonetheless a
sheriff they drove around I didn't hear
you and then somebody else show them
yeah they were down there just doe 15
maybe 20 minutes the tops you know and
they were picking up things so it
students and this doctor busker that
they called him this one girl went up
and said look doctor we wouldn't just
make a beautiful ring she was holding
one with like a red rod red tube of some
kind of kind of a silvery red and he
kind of snapped at her you know
put that down Agnes you don't know what
that is I think it hurts you don't pick
this stuff up and she kind of said well
yeah okay doctor and then he went back
to what he was doing and she wants what
I put in her pocket and a lot of more
doing this were picking up things and
feeling things I was picking up things
and feeling things it was all kinds of
material metal stuff laying around then
we heard it I heard it whoo what we all
heard it a sound of a motor coming like
a truck and I went back at the the
incline there to the to the ridge line
and I see that there was a truck coming
up it was an old pickup truck was sort
of a beige color or a tan colored Anna
what
and it stopped and this guy got out he's
wearing brown clothes he's got boots on
and he's wearing a straw hat just like
the kind Harry Truman always wore and he
had wire-rimmed glasses he was a big man
and he looked exactly like Harry Truman
to me and I knew I had seen in the movie
tone news that he was president then
yeah I was well aware Harry Truman was
sire but was he that kind of a hero you
know this guy looked like an except bit
bigger and now I'm thinking and he
didn't look as old either
his hair was some kind of light gray and
he walked over there and they've got to
talk and me I mean good everybody and he
told them that he worked out on the
plains out there and he made maps and he
had seen the the wreckage from out there
on the plains and he saw the people he
thought was a plane wreck in the you
know something was going on he came over
here to see and he hadn't been there but
just a very very few minutes when we
heard all kinds of motors and strains
and stuff and here comes a military car
with a big white star on the side of it
followed by a six by which is a military
truck with a kind of canvas wagon type
of canvas saying over in his full
soldiers and get guns and right behind
that was what we call fort line which is
like a medium sized truck situation and
had two big night with antennas all
kinds of radio gear in it back and a guy
back here with earphones and stuff on
and he's you know working these radios
and they all pulled up and stopped
which direction that they come from they
came from from the north from worth the
horse Springs area rich so they cut them
off the highway there oh yeah I'm not
sure that's exactly I think I didn't
come off the highway same way we did
well in the mean time that when it
stopped the black soldier the sergeant
and the reason I know he was a sergeant
my brother told me he was and he got out
of this this car and then a guy got out
on the other side and he was the Glen
City was and it was a cafeteria later
he's a captain and this guy had orange
red hair and all the soldiers of him
came running over there pointing guns at
people on tell get away get away get
away you know and when his creature saw
these people the military he went nuts
he went into an absolute panic worse
than what he did when he saw us did he
move around or just designs he just he
just Oh looked crazy and it was like he
was looking for yeah like he's looking
for a place to run and hide but he never
got up there got he never left the one
injured when next to him had this
redheaded officer this guy was a real
butthole he made all the threats he
threatened to
have you shot they do everybody get away
go away you know well [ __ ] get away from
there this is a military secret you know
I'm just screaming and hollering and he
he told my my uncle and my father that
they didn't want to spend the rest of
their life in prison they would never
say anything about what they saw there
they ever wanted to see us kids again
they'd take the kids away they'd never
see the kids you know meaning me and
Victor that we better keep our mouth
shut if we did not this is what was
going to happen they were threatening
people and pushing people and students
as well the Holly out there were there
were hustling everybody and one of the
soldiers pushed my my uncle he had
I guess we should be back I got a lot of
sudden you don't do that intended
violent temper and he grabbed the rifle
reached over top smack this guy dropped
it right there
Ted it dropped five drop with half this
guy's a cowboy hitch Internet and of
course when he did that there was both
opened and I guess cocking they were
talking their rifles and they're
pointing guns at people and everybody
buster and Glenn dead grab him you know
pulling back and going away no matter
how [ __ ] don't do that you know trying
to stop this I think we came very close
to having someone shot then it really
started threatening
well did the redhead do all the talking
pretty much pretty much except once in a
while the sergeant with you know we
chime in and make statements like that
to other people in response to the
reddit mainly it was the redhead was
there a nametag
yes there was and his name was Armstrong
and I not sure if I know that from
having read it or know that from
remembering it now being able to read it
in my memory or someone said that to me
but his name was Armstrong was right
here on as you know now they chased you
guys away pretty quick yeah yeah II did
and they herded us up on cattle and who
just up the Arroyo back in the direction
we come from over the protest of this
dr. Buskirk and said now we've got to go
the other way we came from I don't care
where you came from get ass up the the
Arroyo and it ran us up the oil and so
you get to your car right now they take
us up to your royal and just followed
the hill that we came down they broke us
off and moved us up the hill now this
whole time no one has ever frisked us
down no one has ever checked your
pockets to see if we picked up in his
material and this girl Agnes still has
that stuff in her pocket and some of the
other students head step to my knowledge
had to up to that point they had not
been searched whether they did so
afterward I don't know they never
searched us ever it run us back up the
hill and when we got to where the car
was parked
we're dead it parked the car up there
there's a jeep with a guy sitting in the
back and there's a mounted machine gun
in the back of his Jeep and all these
soldiers the Jeep pulls out we're told
of them getting in the car we followed a
jeep and we'll those soldiers go with us
all the way back out to the highway and
we get back out to the highway they set
us right there they wouldn't let us out
the car that wouldn't let us move
forward I don't know where they're
making a decision or what when we got
out the highway this place was
absolutely full of the military
personnel military equipment there was
airplanes sitting up there that he had
landed on the highway did you see any
airplanes when you were back at the Sun
yeah there was our planes in the sky but
nobody thought much about it you know I
didn't think anything about it I was
used to airplanes being in the sky
having you know been raised in
Indianapolis Indiana the owner the
Norden bombsight you know the sky was
always full
aircraft never fun up about it and we'll
get back onto the highway there's
observation aircraft you know high wind
aircraft and there's one what I know now
to be a c-47 set in there and how we
didn't hear that lands beyond me and how
he'll aunt well course I guess you could
land if you're a good pilot out there is
a known probable pulsar hang and it was
they had toward the fence down on the
north side of that highway and all this
equipment was setting back up there that
plane was up there they were taking
stuff out of the plane there was
military ambulances and there was trucks
with like wreckers
cranes on and there was tankers like
maybe a few or water in him it was just
everywhere you look there was military
and major recovery operation yeah it
looked like an invasion force it really
did and they were all wearing these
these white light khaki uniforms they
didn't look like a holly dress they were
light khaki and they all had the same
patch over there that kind of blew funny
patch with the circles on was was on his
shoulder and a lot of any clue as to
where they came from did your brother I
don't know where they came from
I don't think it's very a certain down
there were a lot of empty patches and it
were when some of more white knights
ticks off of these webbed utility belts
they had nine sticks and they had 45s
and hoster gentleman
they automatics in a forward roaster and
the other were the people were given
most of the orders they had the road
barricaded off out there and we sit
there for a very long time and you were
thirsty and everything we asked you if
we could go back to Horse Springs get
some corn oh no no you can't go through
there and right after that they said no
you just turn out and you head out of
here now and you go to Socorro and you
and this is a redhead again you keep
your mouth shut
just keep going and don't look back well
we drove way on deadness and he'll it
will go to Magdalene
that's where John Trujillo relative 10
and so as we drove away I was looking
out the back window and I could see dr.
Buskirk and these kids and that guy that
got out of the pickup was standing there
and this doctor Buskirk was doing just
like this and this redheaded officers
face and he kept pointing back behind
him and I guess that meant you know we
got to go back that way and he was fed
up with the sky or something he was
shaking his finger in his face were
yelling at each other and that's pretty
much the last I saw the whole situation
I don't know what happened after that
because we just kept going you get home
before dark
oh yeah yeah I was before dark or
Salutin summertime's in a different way
and we stopped in magdalena very briefly
and kept going
and the adults were really funny you
know they were really scared and I had
very rarely you know of course I didn't
know him that well but over the years I
knew that it was not much of a
disciplinarian and he really did
disappoint the kids that much but he
really not the fire out a little victory
victory we wanted to talk about what we
decide you saw tickets on you shut don't
talk about nobody's talking about this
finally he has turn around not to live
in hell out of Victor for shooting his
mouth off did ten work at Sandia yes he
did was did something out there in the
technical area kind of clear yes and
waiting your dad worked out it's a yes
he did a security worked her for years
to reach
every time dad had some very odd
occurrences okay when we got home mom
was over at uncle Ted's house
perceived instantly that something was
wrong
- what's wrong ladies
they decided to tell her what when he
did that course Isabel oh my god you saw
demons you saw the devil because Isabel
was text ads wife about the religious
Catholic person who thinks anything that
isn't a vision and say the Virgin Mary
or of Jesus is quote unquote
demons and that's what we saw and of
course Ted you should put it on and we
really never talked about it much in the
family because of the reaction in God
and my dad was really afraid and so was
Ted there Glenn is special because Glenn
made the statement but when he first saw
the military he told my mother he said
and Ted and everybody there don't let
that sumbitch's know I'm a marine don't
let them know
and of course nobody did and he was as
they close you know kept pair of blue
jeans I
it was a-sayin clothes so he didn't look
like military ER I'm sure his acid real
and they never checked they just assumed
yeah I guess that we the masking oh yeah
they took our names they got a live from
my dad and my brother just very cursory
with drippers hard talk to him all you
like that do most of the talking
the circumstances of course they never
really asked me any questions at all
you're just kidding it was just again
and well you first went public with this
now let's first square away all the
other four that you were with it did yes
it's been some time my brother died of a
heart attack in Mexico City my dad died
of heart attack and 78
Ted and visual filled an automobile
accident in mid 16 I assume under 65
right now there's a strange diary that's
turned up how did that happen well when
I went to my father's funeral in 1978 a
lot of deaths belongings were personal
belongings were given us we didn't live
in the area oh no they were gone off
with the military and I've been in the
military and subsequently in terms of
military
and your dad had remarried a couple of
times oh yeah
this was so dead was on his third wife
and he his personal belongings and stuff
you know kind of give it to my cheek
brothers and myself
my cousin belly Jean there's a funeral
that's Ted's daughter yes and she came
up and was talking to
and she said here
you were there you need to have this too
and she handed me these photocopies and
at first you know I thought what is this
dad's there and she said no it's my
dad's diary but you were there you need
to have this and that daughter because I
read
and so I said yeah okay you know and I
didn't want to talk about it to funeral
because Roz's side of the family god
bless your dad's third wife bless her
lunder but they were very religious and
it would have viewed this exactly the
same way as Isabella had as evil and I
really didn't want to have any problems
with
kind of shaking terms we didn't see a
hide i religiously sort of not quite to
your active in religion now audience
you're a deacon in the Episcopal Church
right okay that means you actively
participate well yeah lay your Christian
ministry fly yes I actively participated
I serve on the altar what do you do for
a living
I'm a security officer of the state
Missouri and you've been doing police
start of work for several years but
years all go and you also are going to
college to be a nurse and you've already
got a couple of associate degrees from
community colleges right yes I want to
social science and one associate or
general studies and I'm working toward
my Bachelors of nursing roughly two
years I have my Bachelor of Nursing LBL
now to be a security officer you have to
be licensed by the state of Missouri -
yes you have to be a certified law
enforcement officer which means that you
have to go on to the state Academy the
Department of Commerce's so that's not
just the basic thing oh no you have to
assume profession in system
and you have to work for the state under
these conditions you have to Nelly be
certified the champion for law
enforcement expiry when we get back to
the diary for just a minute when you are
hypnotized by John Carpenter a
psychiatric social worker and he was
asking you questions about the diary
apparently you've been told that there
were a number of copies of that around
yeah
something buried out maybe there trivia
as I understood well in fact in
conversations with Valley Jean after the
fact after I got involved in his saying
through the unsolved mysteries thing I
was told that that wasn't the only diary
that what I had was it was a copy was a
photo okay and that there were a lot of
these copies around and apparently uncle
Tim or someone had had put these out
through different people in the family
and Frances
for reasons I don't know to keep her
from getting lost or something like that
okay now when I asked you for the
original you contacted who what would
you have le gee that was Valley Geno but
she was in a convent right and she was
reluctant to do anything you had to call
a number of times in cyber that's that's
correct and you talked to the bishop
somebody times yeah I talked to addition
and he convinced her to send the stuff
to me yes apparently because I got
directly from Colorado with a cover
letter that strongly indicated that she
didn't want any more to do with this
that was part of the agreement but that
she considered this the work of the
devil words to that effect anyway he
said I thought she's of the same opinion
see all I have padded this was was the
photographic copies that I had showed
you originally and as I understand it
you received our is the original from
rich those have been made they were
partly burnt she mentioned she had
intended to burn them but because of
your persistence and with the agreement
that I never contacted her she would
send them to me and as you know when I
had forensic analysis done it showed
that the ink dated from the early 70s
the paper could have been available in
47 so it's clearly not an original but
it was also done before there was any
publicity about this case anyway because
I know I was the first one getting wrong
exactly now as you know we have
discovered not on but you had identities
done by a police artist other various
people involved in this right and as you
know there was a picture several
pictures that seemed to indicate the
doctor Buskirk was dr. Winfred Buskirk
who had received his PhD at the
University of New Mexico and he would
describe them as in his late 30s early
40s it turns out he was 39 in 1947 he
was bald involved most of his life
[Music]
it was there other contact between you
and hey at that time as far as you know
your family and Hammer ha I don't know
I'm not wondering
I don't not to my knowledge I don't I
don't believe my dad had ever contacted
him it is a possibility that Ted may
have I'm not sure why I think Valley
Jean had alluded to the fact that Ted
had been in contact with him
that they had corresponded this kind of
thing but as far as personal knowledge
okay now you didn't tell your story
really until the unsolved mysteries
program was rerun in January of 1990
that's right that's when you contacted
them got my address drove me
yeah I've been ran balanced where
they'll upset but the program wasn't
quite accurate well yeah that was the
whole thing started off as a flood to
begin with because everything I saw
didn't didn't jive with what I had seen
personally I guess I was kind of miffed
you know here all these years I had been
primarily forced you know but not only
by others but by you know my own sense
of survival to keep my mouth shut
well here it is it's on TV and he got it
wrong as I just impulsively called the
number and told the lady wait a minute
II know plague was wrong why do you know
that sir and I said well because I was
there that's flying
apparently pulled somebody's stirring
yeah the key thing that was wrong of
course there were a few mistakes in
another ones excellent program was that
they had that the Barney Barnett the
civil engineers story over near Corona
and you knew that it was over in the
plains right there's a lot more well
yeah and the fact that the thing looked
like a tent flat her a tent top hat it
didn't it was this shape and Barney
Barnett or whoever the guy the truck was
did not drive right up to it on road it
wasn't parked conveniently next to a
thoroughfare had though it was just
things like that I I don't know I just
for some reason I thought why you know
Chief look it's already publicly yeah it
story's out and let's get it right you
know of course I didn't I don't think I
realized at the time you know how
involved this was going to be fit what
kind of real level or now I got you
together with the John Carpenter the
psychiatric social worker and you guys
had several sessions and then we flew
out to the site you're reasonably
convinced now that the second time
around that we fit didn't find the exact
location yeah
the first time in I you know it was like
forty three years and we're at a
helicopter but I would never yeah I was
in the air this time in the last time I
was on the ground and so you know the
landmarks for a little confusing I was
positive I was in the right place but
until he actually got on the ground John
and I and retraced the room in there
that we had come in in the car I was
absolutely sure there was two ridge
lines there and I wasn't really sure
which one it was and I had the feeling
that the first one that I had pointed
out was the correct one but once
on foot with John I knew instantly that
it wasn't that one it was the other one
and I'm absolutely positive that that's
where I was at restaurant question in my
mind and you will recall that you
described the woman who sold you the pop
on the way in right and they found the
older woman there who said that was
exactly what she looked like
right now I'll never forget that lady
because I a lot had it with me I'm
telling you
back seat of that 40 Plymouth done of
dirty old roads and stuff and for mile
after mile of course my dad was one of
these kind of people when he got in a
car it was point A to point B non-stop I
don't know why he just never stopped
solid roses along the way and so you
know I was pretty sad shape
what kind of response have you had he
went public I mean John talked to a
newsman you both talked he called me in
Springfield was very people paper
carried a very straight very large
article and that got spread around by
lots of people so suddenly you're a
celebrity if he will what kind of
reaction from the people who leave on
campus where you work you're all very
very few negatives there there's the
noisy negative this you know we had
but in general it hits the general inner
or 99% of the people were incredibly
supportive only one professor at the
University was of the dangerous type it
was vocal about it everybody else just
100% supporting the majority of these
people are absolutely convinced even
without this story that extraterrestrial
life-forms exist and that the people are
flying around out there and moving
between systems and stuff and it was
just it's just a unbelievable amount of
supporting you didn't lose your job
oh no why I didn't give you heart
absolutely not in fact I think it's I
can I can publicly say that my boss was
extremely supportive because he is a
avid ufologist himself he is fascinated
by the subject
you won't have any problem convincing
him either and my boss has a master's
degree he's not someone it's untrained
observer that's given the hallucination
most of the people who are the most
supportive of me our people are very
high education is very very solid
education very solid understanding
degree people not given the
hallucination you went you attended a
UFO conference so with John Carpenter
and he gave a paper I guess and
introduced you and you've got to respond
serve that audience - yeah 100%
supporting I was really quite relieved
and made very very welcome well you've
been interviewed by a number of other
people Linda Howe working on a
documentary and so forth that seems to
evoke this turnout how much contact did
you have with Kevin Randle a very brief
telephone call I came home from work one
day and there was a message on my
answering machine and as you well know I
have a tendency to be hard to get home
yes he'd left his number and of course I
had his address and I in US and I had
sent cards to both of you something to
the effect if you want to know what
really happened after he called Mia and
he had called and I wasn't there and he
had left his number so I returned his
call
I talked to him very briefly primarily
because I didn't like the man's attitude
I don't feel comfortable with people who
call other people liars and charlatans
and phonies and say that they rigged
their research to make it come out the
way they want and when someone starts
telling me this kind of thing then the
first thing I want to do is I want to
get away from them and this is exactly
what he did now I understand this man
claims that I talked to him for two
hours and he has a two-hour tape one
contradiction after another to me and
that's not quite true
okay there's been no other contact with
no other contact I won't give the man a
time of day has any other investigator
any of the noisy negative its approach
to during them none at all the only
other investigators you yourself or Don
Berliner and Bob Bigelow John Carpenter
and you're quite familiar with our
article and you agree that on that first
trip to the plains it was you I Bob the
glow and a pilot in the helicopter yeah
Joe Charlie the pilot was in the front
seat on the left side I was in the front
seat on the right side you were directly
behind me no you were directly behind
the pilot on the left side of Bob
Bigelow was directly behind me on the
passenger side right and then we met up
with eventually with the Don Berliner
and Mike carpenter they were at like
three days they wrote to Dahle drove the
jeeps and stuff to Dowlen we're waiting
for a sudeva when we landed in the
highway right and as you recall where
did we refuel the helicopter
Springer Dale Arizona because there's
not Florida Arizona that's oh no no it
was just a matter of a few minutes
actually
30 25 25 minutes maybe it's maxed west
of where we located all right I think we
may pick this up another time but I
think that will do it for now really
appreciate the time trouble and effort
and all the rest of that and on the
bigger and better thing yes I like your
red scene sets driving essentially what
they remember bargains it's just a nice
part of the world abilities yeah I'm
Rachel healthy let's see how our tinker
toys are all put together if we got on
any kind of an audio well yeah if you
just want to give me a little bit of
what you just say couple things
what's okay first of all the phone was
ringing right okay the wait really the
way I became involved in this was
started out in the after early afternoon
around probably 1:30 in the afternoon I
received a telephone call from the
mortuary officer out at the Walker Air
Force Base Army Airfield basin
and he was requiring inquiring about
what would be the smallest possible
casket that we could get that would be
dramatically sealed and at that time I
know that we had used like the fourth
feet and caskets we had used those
before but I thought they also made them
in at three six so but I he want to know
if we had any and stopped and I said no
but I could make a called a Marella I
can have him in you know by seven
o'clock the next morning on the truck
Singh said I'll get back to you and that
was the first contact that I had with
the base event one then he called back
hope probably 45 minutes or so later and
he said I need to ask you some more
questions he said in case something like
this should happen he said we we need to
know what the preparation would have
what your preparations are for the
bodies that had been laying out in the
elements you know and he said we need to
know also what what if your treatments
of the bodies are the remains what could
you do to them and if your treatments
would it would it change any of the
chemical breakdown of the tissues the
blood would it make a difference and I
said I thought probably it would and I
said of course he knew exactly how we
would treat those bodies because we have
an outline from them and what we really
have to do I think here--it that he
already at that point he exactly what we
would have to do disclose to you what he
had no I told him I said if you if you
have a problem if you want do you know
if you have something you don't really
know what to do about it let me come out
and I'll you know try to help you do
whatever you want to do
and he said and he said no he said let's
start again with your singing you told
him come on take care of what he got
right yeah so he said well you know we
don't really have anything he said we're
sitting here thinking case we should get
involved in something like this you know
what would be our preparation what would
should we do then I you know I went
through I said do you really want to
know how we would do it well yes you
know we would like to know so that's
when I explained to him that we would
have the vats that we would fill up with
a with formaldehyde solution with water
and we put the bodies in him let him
stay there for 24 hours and then take
them out and then we would pack the
bodies in would be a saw destin really a
lime so what we would pack them in and
wrapped him in the blessed that was
bodies that were badly decomposed if
there was tissue deep tissue we would
have to do it hypodermic lee with
needles to get to the deep tissue then
we would have to aspirate the cavities
if the cavities hadn't already ruptured
and then put some cavity fluid in those
I said that's you know kind of normal
procedure now at one point you finally
offered to take care of it for them well
four to three times yeah what that
conversation you may want to offered to
take care of them he said well we don't
really right at this time we don't
really need your assistant but he said
in case something like this should
happen and he said we would be prepared
and we would know what to do then we got
back onto the subject of maybe not
damaging any of the the chemical
compounds or anything with the bodies
are you
no tissues whatever because it they
wanted you know how do you would you
pick bodies up like that and what would
you do not to to contaminate any of it
just begin to see those strains to at
that point well I thought maybe what
happened they might have had a VIP or
you know some off certain something that
happened they maybe they didn't want you
know want to keep it quiet and even
probably want to do it themselves not be
involved with the civilian businesses
anything so after these conversations
you were curious and you went on out to
the base as I understand it can you
review well no I didn't go out to the
base yeah I was curious but then I
didn't go out to the base and probably a
couple of hours later and I've got an
emergency call it was an airman that was
injured in an accident and I took the
airman to the base he wrote in the
ambulance with me and I take him out to
the merchant streamer and that's why I
became really involved at the base I
didn't go out just because I was curious
give me the sequence from the time he
picked up the other and just described
me well and I got the call you know I
left feeling home and the hamlets went
to the scene of the accident picked the
airman up he did not place him on a
stretcher because yet it had injury and
a nose I think his nose was fractured so
I did some minor first-aid and then he
sat in the front seat with me all the
way to the base when we got to the base
then he walked into the emergency room I
didn't have to take him in and they
didn't bring out a you know a gurney or
anything we just he just walked in on
his own then I never did see him after
that
then I had this friend that I wanted to
talk to and say this is the lieutenant
nurse that I knew quite well that had
only been there approximately only been
commissioned and bent out to sign this
was her first assignment to the head up
to the air base and I wanted to talk to
her and so this I was going down
all and I the first thing the lady that
I want the latet that I wanted to see he
was coming out of one room going across
the hall to the other she noticed me she
said how did you get in here and what
are you doing in here and she said you
better get out and her she said you're
going to get in a lot of trouble she
said would you please leave and get out
of here and hurry
and then about I turned around and then
about and she went on into the other
room then about the time I turned around
there was a there was another officer
said wait wait a minute
and I said looks like you had a crash he
said I see there's some you know in the
animal said in the hamlets is out there
I see lot of recognize it
where was the crash and he said there
wasn't any crash and he said and he said
just wait a minute and then died he said
wait a minute at night you know stood
there for a minute he turned around and
he would that leave must wait for
somebody else to come up because there
was another officer coming out he said
this man says it was a crash out at the
base he said he wanted to know God he
was inquiring about our crash and this
was when I encountered he was a
redheaded officer and a very nasty very
gruff he said he did not see any crash
there was not any cat crash and he said
you get the hell out of here and you
didn't see anything and you don't talk
to anybody he said you got to get in
hell a lot of trouble and I said look
I'm surveying the damn thing you can do
to me about it he said no but somebody
might be picking your bones out of sand
that's when he made the remark there
then there was a black sergeant that was
standing beside him and he said yeah but
he would make better dog food for our
dogs because I didn't understand that
but my father happened to be an old
trapper and for a hobby and everything I
said my father uses guys like you for
bait and his cow traps and then there
was two MPs that joined me
don't take me outside he told to me by
my elbows and they escorted me out to
the back to the Amundsen followed me all
the way back to the FEMA home now as you
were entering the hospital you saw
something three times
yeah when yep because Jesus Lee where I
parked there was three field ambulances
right in the area where I usually Park
we'll be back up to them to the ramps so
I just pulled up to the side in front of
those and parked out the front the
airmen and I got out and walked in so
when I passed when I got up went up the
steps up the ramp and I was walking
going into the emergency room I noticed
that the doors were open and then there
but what was odd about it there was an
MP standing beside each one of the
vehicles in the back standing there and
the doors were open naturally I was
curious and you know I just happened to
look in that's when I saw some debris it
looked like parts of a plane or
something that they hadn't had a crash
because I've seen him do this a lot of
times bring in pieces and the olam
lenses in can you describe the debris
they were I noticed in two of the
ambulances there was some debris that
was probably two and a half to three
feet you know long and probably high
that was propped up on the side of the
ambulance there they were kinda in the
shape of maybe like a half a canoe they
they were like the front part of a canoe
and but you know did look like it looked
like it might be aluminum but it looked
more like it was the metal look more
like stainless steel that had been
heated it was blue kind of Bush Ted hood
what was thought about it it looked like
around the curved part in the front of
the canoe there was some that some
designs or something it kind of reminded
me of maybe some Egyptian signs or
whatever and it was probably about three
inches and high and probably the length
of what the wreckage I saw it look like
it was the ring and the same thing was
and then the other Emmons - you mean I
saw practically the same thing the
pieces that were practically the same
size and then Cygnus looked like
whatever that might be was part of the
wreckage how it made
how did she Frank yoga what she saw well
I didn't know really until until the
till the next day and I wanted to I
called out I kept trying to get a hold
of her because naturally I was curious
and I want to know what was going on and
so I called out the next day and then
probably around 11:30
she said I know you've been trying to
get a hold of me but I haven't been
available and she said why don't you
meet me at the officer's club if you'd
if you have time EPL's Club and we'll
have lunch and I wanted to know what to
talk to you and the funeral home we had
it at that time we had all the son of
the businesses there had an associate
membership to the officer's club
and our funeral home had that membership
and also had a card to identify myself
and what business that I was you know
associated with so I had no problem
anytime I go to base all that dude a lot
of times if it was in the evening I that
stop sign of esters and get a visitor's
pass and then turn it in when I left
there was no problem going out there so
I went on out met her baked bread
covered Barlow's well we you know both
ordered I'm not sure remember what we
ordered but it was just a light just a
light lunch but she was so upset she
looked like she's you know in shock
because what she really talked like and
looked like and she said I wanted she
said I said well I've just curious on
reason I want to talk to you it was
curious and what happened and she said
well you won't believe it she says I
don't believe it either but she said I
got in a lot of trouble on this thing
probably I'm not real sure about this
but she said my knight then she pulled
out of a little purse or little
pocketbook whatever she had there she
gave me a little diagram that she had
that she had drawn some drytown some
figures of some arms in faith and so on
she told me that this is what you know
was what was in those that it was a
crash wasn't an airplane but they didn't
know what it was at that time these were
Bobby yeah but she said we have three
bodies that there was three bodies she's
at two of them were very mutilated one
looked like it might have walked out her
that it will you know might have lived a
little while and she explained they were
like three and a half feet four feet
tall the team of the bodies were you can
identify much because they were
practically destroyed and it looked like
maybe that they might have been a
predatory animal or something might have
been dead some damage on the bodies to
how she described her head your hands
well she said that you had in the
delivered drawings that I had she had
way she explained it in way she'd read
that the heads were somewhat larger than
then a human heads the hands were long
no thumbs they were just along very
delicate fingers at the end of the month
I decided at the tip of each fingers was
a pad like maybe a little pad but it
looked like the skin had maybe little
suction like little suction cups on
those on the no fingernails on the hands
the head the lips were very just a long
narrow more or less not full lips like
we would have in most of our people but
very fine line very fine lips
there was no teeth that was the inside
of the mouth it was it was kind of like
a real
uh again maybe it was she said explain
it was almost as hard as if it was
rawhide maybe at that the years there
was only two small officers on each side
of the head would look like a couple of
small lobes at might some way that might
cover both of those but there was not a
treating year and also that the nose
there was only two small offices and
knows that where there was there was
really no nose that was the convex it
was old just flesh with the hint of the
face was she emotional very much so very
emotional she would have stopped drink
water every once in a while and also she
never touched a meal it all the time we
were talking in an hour and a half that
we were there she never touched her meal
any other demonstrations of emotions
except well just you know where would
someone she'd go like this you know then
wringing her hands and she said there's
the most most horrid so horrified in my
life I've never seen anything so
gruesome in my life never smelt anything
that smelt the worst in my life and she
told me that when I saw her she was
leaving the room to go to the bathroom
because she was deathly ill and was good
to throw up did she recognize any of the
doctors by damming the body she told me
she said I don't I asked you that
question which the doctors and she said
I don't know that she said I don't know
that I knew them and that was her answer
so but she said she walked in the room
and they said hey we need you you need
to help us and that was where she became
involved and then she got ill the
doctors would also became very ill they
would have to do a little examination
then they'd have to leave and go said
and then they would come back and do a
little bit more it was that bad after
conversation with her at lunch can you
describe what happened that did you see
how you were unable to see her again and
how you burn well yeah we bested well
and then I had to get back to the
funeral home go back to work but then I
never did see her after that and I
called out the next day to see how she
was feeling see what and they told me
that she wasn't available then I
wouldn't be available that day I call
the next day and they told me that she
had been transferred and it was rather
odd because she had only been at the
base less than three months that was her
non-commissioned less than three months
and that was her first assignment so it
was rather odd that she would be
transferred out you know within three
months so later on you attempt to do I
guess you gotta let her then about two
weeks probably two weeks at least two
weeks could have been a little longer
but I know it was at least two weeks I
got a I got a letter addressed to media
clan Edison to Ballard Field home with
she didn't sign it didn't have any
return to address or anything on it but
inside of the letter there was just a
note she said I don't have time to write
I will write a it later this is my APO
number and that was that was the extent
of it so then I wrote back to her and
asking her more or less how you know how
she was failing and why the sudden
transfer and and I hope that she wasn't
in any trouble it was just a short note
I really didn't go into a lot of detail
everything then probably three weeks or
probably a month after that then I got
the letter that I had mailed to her it
was returned it was stepped returned and
also it told them then red printing it
said deceased and that's less time I've
ever heard or heard anything about it
then well probably then I went out to
the base
a few days later and I was talking with
a nurse and I said you know whatever
happened to lieutenant and she said well
the rumor is that we heard that she was
killed with five other nurses in her
training mission in a plane crash and
that was it no indication where well
it's in London English she said in my in
the note that she sent me that she was
in London station in London and that was
it that's the last time I ever heard did
you believe that she's dead
I don't think so after all it's
happening and after you know threatening
me and everything I doubt very seriously
that she was I would hope not what would
you like saving her she happened to see
happen to this say it if she she feels
like the you know she wants to talk if
she feels like I would like to hear from
her yes see what's been going on in her
life and why she wasn't able to contact
me if she you know feels like it it's
not good for
now the sir told father you were in
trouble okay what happened there then
the next day after I was there when I
had the problem with the officer and the
black man I was told my father was
contacted by our sheriff George Wilcox
which was a very close friend of my
father's they were very good friends and
he called to see if my father was home
because he wanted to come out and talk
to my father
and he did so and he told my father that
there was a black sergeant from the base
that came to the to his office was
inquiring about who my parents were my
mother and my father if I had any
brothers or sisters and I'll you know
want to know my what my personal family
who they were and where they were George
said that he didn't he knew I had some
family but he didn't know you know where
they were anything else so anyway he
told my father that he did contact and
father and he told my father that he
thought I might be in some trouble and
but he didn't they evidently didn't
explain why I was in trouble so you know
first thing my father did was get in his
car and come to the funeral home said we
had to talk because he and I were very
close we real you know real good friends
best friend I ever had was my father he
said I've got to talk he said if you're
in trouble he said we got to do
something about and I said I'm not in
trouble
he said well you are he said George
realtor told me that you were in a lot
of trouble and that you got involved in
something that you had no business
getting involved in and that you could
be in a lot of trouble nice again so I
told my father the story and he's the
only man that I've ever told a story to
until
I talked to Stan Friedman and to you
people that's that period and I did tell
my father what what the story was Chris
knew is you know it was unbelievable for
him but then he became very upset and he
wanted to go shoot a few people know
that because they did threaten my life
and you know and they so that was the
way my father heard about it and that
was extent my family and he never would
tell him who my brother I had a brother
that was a fighter pilot during that
time and I had three sisters and one of
them was a nurse but I bet he would
never tell him anything and so he hadn't
L - everybody else because the sheriff
was supposed to come back given the
names where they rat he wouldn't up
let's get back to you did she express an
opinion as to what she thought these
beings were did she think did she think
they came with it
well she all she result the only remark
that she ever made was that they
definitely weren't humans as we know
humans but they could be from another
planet Earth the doctors were explaining
this that they couldn't be from our
planet they had to be an alien had to be
something yes but not not in our planet
she had a phrase to describe how they
look to her remember that they were
telling me like little black [ __ ] no
she said that well of course they were
you know first thing she said they were
black they were just as black as he
could be but probably laying out in the
elements and in July and Roswell with
105 210 typically every day and 80
degrees or so at night I mean that's not
they wouldn't be in common because we
picked up a lot of sheepherders of
people that have been found dead that's
laying in the desert you know for days
and get more rattlesnakes or whatever
and they do turn you know the black as
they can
and I know exactly what they were
talking about because when they'd smell
the odor being so drastic because this
is a very unpleasant situation you know
and just thought about their eyes how
did she describe her eyes
well she said that of course her eyes
were set back into the skull oh and it
was a remarkable I thought it was
interesting also that she said their
skulls
the doctor said their skull bone
structure wasn't like ours it wasn't
actually a bone it was probably a real
heavy cartilage it it looked more or
less like a newborn baby the skull was
very pliable you could mash on the skull
and it would you know it would give and
so at the bone structure it wasn't bones
not like our bones here with our skull
and everything about the bones in the
hand said very fine very delicate the
arm bones they'd like the radial Yeller
and in the arm that there was so fine
that he'd out if they could lift you
know she said they died if they could
anyone and at that size and the arms
that that could lift 50 pounds on the
earth or anywhere else
did you know they doubt it they had that
strength but she said what the one that
hadn't been mutilated to a great extent
it reminded him of a real small ancient
Chinese person no hair at all in a very
very delicate skin fact he said the skin
would look like they could almost see to
it almost transparent why don't you give
me a paragraph on the news and an Oscar
well the years like I think I stated to
you that the years there was a couple of
small orifices one on top of the other
with too little lobe flaps one over the
other they didn't really know how those
if they had any significance how they
worked or what it wasn't I mean they
didn't go into that the nose was only a
couple of very small offices holds right
there
just above the lip line
that it had there was nothing covering
it and it was just like two small
indentations there and that was it
said it was very unusual talk about the
hands
yeah eight the hands well there was one
hand there was there was one hand that
evidently that wasn't attached to the
arm and she said that where she got sick
and left the room was that this doctor
had the long force up and picked the end
up and turn it over and that's when they
noticed there wasn't any thumb none of
them had none of the bodies had any
thumbs or anything that were just long
very fine very delicate fingers no
fingernails but right at the tip of each
finger right at the tip of each finger
it looked like there was a pad and in
this pad it looked like it might have
had very small little they were like
little suction cups but very good
suction cups the doctors that's where he
explained it that was looking at it
Hey okay yes they all know that we need
to pull about the aisle seat so that we
get some tubs of other people dinner I
just go take Kmart or wherever and buy
now why don't we start with he talked
about the handsome for continuity mighty
good to go tomorrow
this'll all be gathered in anyway but we
can start where we like one let's start
with the arms okay forget the camera
I've seen a piece of it it's not there
but you were asking me to describe the
arms and this was another thing that did
lieutenant write out that it was that it
was very the difference between theirs
and ours that that they're from the
wrist to the first joint here that it
was probably one and a half times longer
than the top part up here you
that was very odd-looking it was very
odd she said and the very small very
small arms very small bone structure
bone structure was bone structure
because I asked her about the bones
because we were talking about the wrist
bones and everything and she said it was
very similar to hers but the bones were
so small that that their bones probably
wouldn't end in the armed wasn't he
larger than my finger okay that give me
two three sentences on how they were
dressed she we never mentioned it they
were tough that dress did she say
anything about sex or was she everything
she said she really never G was so sick
and everything that never even entered
her mind
so was it nobody to determine the sex of
the beings then well it wasn't discussed
with her it probably was but she like
she said I was so ill and so horrified
that that I don't you know she said she
sat up all night and then she knew I was
going to be real concerned knew I was
going to be on what happened you know
she knew that I got in trouble probably
and she would true that do you know she
set up and made a little notes on the
back of these little prescription pads
and that's what she had her notes made
out and that's what we discussed
particularly what she had I was very
interested that you had kept so many
records of the incident and pertaining
to everything that you know regarding
the UFO fraction and you kept them in
the you know they're at Ballard's and
then later they disappeared
well I was really in charge of all the
military contracts I did all the bids
and everything and really took care of
all the contracts myself and that was
that was one of my duties at funeral
take care of the military and I had a
file I had a file on everything it ever
happened that Walker Air Base to like
Bob Hope and different some of the big
August
everybody come and have the big parties
and everything in the hangars you know
attended but I would also have pictures
in everything I had a personal file that
I kept and I kept everything in this
file that that that pertain that I
attended or whatever and this is where I
put the diagrams and the notes that she
gave me was in my personal file well
then the Ballard funeral home sold at a
later date several years later that it
sold and the people that bought the
funeral home these word files that they
were the old files that that that they
kept in the basement down in the furnace
room and they had all the milk I had all
the military files together in one
filing cabinet everything had happened
at the base and everything we also had
the contract at Fort Sumner Air Base the
attic lighter base there and also a
fighter pilot training there and the
p-47 and 51s and so on and so I had all
the files everything was one filing
cabinet was strictly all military and
that's where I had all this filed away I
had all this filed away I even had a
newspaper that Walter Haught the
headlines no list the next day I had all
that in his files what interests me is
that I've always filed he has different
topic only one was missing when he went
to look for it that was one pertaining
to this yeah can you review that for us
well no they're some of the other files
were missing also not just my own file
but my file was in the same that yeah
most of most all my files my father was
gone but there was also some files they
had really actually had destroyed most
of the files that were obtaining after
certain years they just got rid of them
and they told the manager funeral home
that's managed their name Raymond Otero
also told me that he knew my file was
there Joe Lucas that was a manager at
that time knew my files were there and
he and I'd had some personal problems
then
he said get rid of the you know get rid
of his dam filed we don't anything
remind us of him that's where the files
went really there was some discussion
about how to preserve the bodies but dry
ice and that sort of thing and oh well
like where they got the ice okay this
okay they tend to mortuary softer what
okay how would what would you do if you
had to ship one out and but you couldn't
do anything two minutes you couldn't you
know did any trade machine what would
you do that's the only thing you could
do that I would suggest the first thing
if you have a problem don't want to
destroy the tissue any any blood cells
anything that you don't want to destroy
how would suggest that you contact a
pathologist and I said I'm sure the the
Army Airfield I mean somebody's got some
pathologist around I didn't know that
they had one in Roswell but I said fire
you I'd call the pathologist and take
you know ask him what how he would like
to have it done or whatever you're going
to do or whatever it is you better do
what the pathologist because these ones
going to do the autopsy make the reports
but I said the only thing I know you
could do is just pagoda clarity's dara
sunset Creamery we had to you at the
time and by all the dryest you can and
pack them in dries if that's possible
and that's what I suggest that they do
no sorry about that at least eight times
all the other none personal okay I think
he has a suggestion you might want to do
that part again if you
I'd like to use it because I asked about
a hitter just a few times no sorry about
this it is he pick you later when Dad is
take 2:30 all right let's go back and go
over the dry ice thing again well okay
what I suggested that the more to the
mortuary off so I suggested this to the
mortuary officer at the way and we we
discussed this problem for 20 minutes
from better on the telephone and I said
I kept telling him hey you know if you
have a problem if you got something out
there if you need our services we have
the contract I would be glad to come out
and help you take care of it he said no
this is for future kept always referring
this was for future use in case we did
have something but then I I said well
you know first thing you'd better do you
better get a hold of a pathologist I
don't know whether you have one at the
base I don't but I know you probably had
the top pathologist you know something
similar those words and I said that's
what I do and you better let him give
you the instruction and then you better
do what he tells you to do because these
ones going to do the autopsy and you
know if that's if it's this sensitive
you better do what he tells you but I
said the only other suggestion I can
make that you go to clarity's dairy or
you go to Sunset Creamery buy all the
dry ice you can impact whatever you have
whatever the problem is you better pack
it and dry us and then do whatever you
have to do with it because that's the
only way they tried to put it in the
morgue doctor morgue they had two
refrigerated body compartments that we
used to put him in then we'd go out and
get the bodies from there but they
always brought the airman to us but on
the dependents and everything we went
out for them that they weren't cold
enough in the end it became so offensive
they were afraid they were going to you
know we were going to upset everybody in
the hospital so they later moved him
over to a hangar and that's less than
Sheen anything about him - lieutenant
you anything about him but she didn't
know how they moved it or anything about
it but they were taken to a hangar
because the effect that odor was so
offensive they can did like they said it
was upsetting everything it's three
fantastic yeah did she tell you where
she thought of where she was told the
bodies went Rosa I'm sorry
what about he went from rug did you know
what where they were shipped up did you
know where they went
she didn't know she never told me she
never mentioned any no suggestion
whatsoever she just said the last she
heard they were in hanger and that's all
she knows and we never discussed
anything else I guess if that takes care
of everything would you like to watch it
why does the portion on just to get an
idea you'll need to watch the whole
picture yeah let's turn it around watch
it